sind die theorien über quasare alle
falsch sind die hellsten objekte in
unserem kosmos sie strahlen im
sichtbaren licht mit einer leuchtkraft
die bis zu zehn hoch 14 mal größer ist
als die der sonne
es handelt sich um die zentren von
aktiven galaxien bisher ging man davon
aus dass der wandel einer galaxie zum
casa tausende jahre dauert doch es
scheint ganz anders zu sein und das
verrückte es ist zumindest zurzeit
unerklärlich klick zum 25 action gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst er nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
der name dieser äußerst mysteriösen
objekte leitet sich von quasi stella
abwasser sind die kerne von galaxien die
besonders für radio strahlung aussenden
konkret gesagt in quasare der helle kern
von aktiven galaxie die unfassbare
leuchtkraft der quasare wird nicht durch
eine thermonukleare fusion verursacht
wie sie etwa im sternen inneren abläuft
stattdessen sorgen schwarze löcher dafür
dass quasare heller leuchten als
milliarden von sternen
diese sitzen in der mitte von großen
galaxien und sind super massereich etwa
so schwer wie ein paar millionen sterne
doch das alleine erzeugt noch nicht die
unfassbare leuchtkraft der quasare
sondern erst ihre kombination mit großen
gaswolken zu finden sind diese überall
in einer galaxie besonders gehäuft aber
tatsächlich in deren zentren wenn sich
solch eine gaswolke dann einem schwarzen
loch nähert bewegt es sich zunächst um
dieses herum in spiralförmigen bahn
wandern die gas zeichen immer weiter auf
das loch zu und fallen irgendwann hinein
eine scheibe aus staub und gas um gibt
also das schwarze loch und leuchtet
dabei extrem hell dadurch dass das
schwarze loch im aktiven galaxienkernen
also gigantische mengen an materie
einsaugt und dadurch energie in form von
strahlung abgibt leuchten war so extrem
hell bei unserer milchstraße dagegen
handelt es sich um das andere extrem das
schwarze loch hier ist so gut wie gar
nicht aktiv doch zwischen diesen beiden
extremen gibt es eine weitere galaxien
klasse in der fachsprache ist von so
genannten linie galaxien die rede sie
sind lange nicht so hell wie quasare
doch in besteht
spektral bereichen strahlen sie extrem
stark ein rätsel für forschungsteams
weltweit ist aber der ursprung dieser
strahlung stammt sie ebenfalls von
schwarzen löchern innerhalb dieser linie
galaxien oder wir sitzen diese galaxien
gar keine supermassereichen schwarzen
löcher in ihrem zentrum wird die
strahlung stattdessen durch gaswolken
sterne oder andere galaktische objekte
verursacht ein us forschungsteam hat
sechs dieser linie galaxien jetzt
mehrere monate lang ins visier genommen
und zwar mit hilfe des automatischen
teleskops am kalifornischen paloma
observatorium schnell wurde klar dass
sich diese sechs galaxien äußerst
merkwürdig verhalten zunächst konnten
die fachleute plötzlich bei einer der
galaxien ein mysteriöses aufleuchten
beobachten
auch die anderen fünf galaxien
leuchteten auf dem forschungsteam wurde
somit schnell klar
bei diesem phänomen kann es sich nicht
um einen kurzzeitigen snack eines
schwarzen lochs halten dass gerade einen
stern einsaugt der ihm zu nahe gekommen
war
das konnten auch analysen im uv und
infrarot bereich ausschließen dazu die
astronomin sarah falle reck die an der
studie beteiligt war
wir stellten fest dass ein zuvor
ruhendes schwarzes loch eine
transformation durch machte die
astronomen einen changing lockt nennen
das ergebnis ist ein heller quasi das
bestätigt dass linie galaxien sehr wohl
aktive supermassereiche schwarze löcher
in ihrem zentrum haben können
doch dieser wandel zum basar vollzog
sich deutlich schneller als es die
theorie erlaubt bislang gingen fachleute
davon aus dass durch eine transformation
tausende von jahren dauert dazu sarah
völlig diese transformationen waren sehr
plötzlich und dramatisch es ist sehr
überraschend dass eine galaxie ihr
aussehen innerhalb menschlicher zeit
massstäbe ändern kann eine sehr
spektakuläre erkenntnis also sogar für
das forschungsteam selbst offensichtlich
funktioniert dieser wandel zum wasser
nach einem mechanismus der noch völlig
unbekannt ist die bisherige theorie dazu
wird jedenfalls durch die aktuellen
beobachtungen der fachleute komplett
über den haufen geworfen
auch wenn alle sechs galaxien
letztendlich ein aktives schwarzes loch
in ihrem zentrum aufweisende handelt es
sich wohl
um eine neue klasse aktive galaxienkerne
dazu schreibt das autorenteam in der
neuen studie die beobachtung dieser
übergänge bei 6 relativ ruhigen linie
galaxien deutet darauf hin dass wir eine
völlig neue klasse aktive galaxienkerne
identifiziert haben
hier müssen extreme und sehr starke
kräfte am werk sein himmelsobjekt heller
als milliarden sterne quasi einfach
erklärt anklicken hier anschauen und
klicks um science-fiction kostenlos
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran